ta fierté de la région regarder ce
garçon il est tout jeune à peine plus de
30 ans
joli sourire il s'appelle merrill un blu
vous dit rien d'assez sur france 3 que
j'ai découvert ce métier il ya très peu
de vanille en france on va pas se le
cacher merrill ouais on entre 250 et 450
donc aussi celle l'année 300 va dire si
je trancherai après il ya beaucoup de
passionnés a quand même beaucoup de
clubs de vannerie un peu dans toutes les
régions
alors votre passion elle transpire on va
en parler ensemble en même temps quand
on voit quelques images sur
quelques-unes de vos très très belle
réalisation j'espère aussi qu'on verra
ce garçon présentait mois le petit
bonhomme de neige qui l'a donc ce
bonhomme de neige que j'ai fait pour
l'année dernière pour les expositions
parce que comme j'ai quand j'expose
avoir une grosse pièce pour être
vraiment visible donc cet hiver mais il
sera mis en location
on va très bien en tout cas ils mesurent
plus de deux mètres il est très très
chouette très sympa je reviens sur votre
métier
le métier vous l'avez appris ou à fayl
billot fayl billot la seule école en
france
ouais on n'est pas loin de la bourgogne
franche comté on est en attente de la
champagne pas très très loin de vesoul
vous vous trouvez quoi c'est quoi trois
quarts d'heure de route - ça ok qu'est
ce que vous avez appris là bas on apprit
ont fait cette série exactement de sept
paniers voilà parce que c'est déjà ce
qu'il faut maîtriser donc c'est à dire
c'est pas en une fois qu'on va les
apprendront il faut les répéter
beaucoup pour vraiment intégré parce que
c'est vraiment des gestes qui ont été
repris depuis nos ancêtres depuis
tellement longtemps et il ya une réelle
transmission derrière ses gestes oui
alors c'est justement ce panier là par
exemple on va on va voir on va voir un
petit à petit et c'est avec vous en même
temps vous pouvez parler ce que vous
pouvez travailler
oui mais c'est super mais j'adore quand
on peut faire plein de choses à la fois
non je vais vous laisser continuer de
travailler
expliquez-moi ce panijel alauzie vous
l'avez trouvé où il vient d'où cette
odier alors c'est aussi hélas c'est
celui que je cultive pas ce que vous
cultivez louzy je cultive losier alors
j'ai une association à fayl billot qui
aide les jeunes vania s'installer et du
coup ils ont une parcelle qui est déjà
en place qu'ils ont mis à disposition
pour les vanniers travailler je vais
tourner un petit peu ça c'est la télé
donc forcément on va truc un petit peu
l'histoire voilà on va faire de jolis de
jolis plans pour qu'on vous voit un
petit peu travaillé sur sur ce panier là
ça paraît très simple comme ça
une certitude c'est qu'on n'utilise pas
n'importe quel osier j'imagine je vais
vous dire losier il faut que ce soit un
petit peu humidifié c'est ça exactement
alors là c'est de l'osi brut
c'est-à-dire losier
avec les corses donc on mouille on le
moule moins que du blanc du blanc sert
il faut fréquemment avec un
pulvérisateur je n'ai pas pu là j'en ai
déjà fait travailler des rosiéristes etc
comme vous des vanniers qui essayait de
faire des choses comme ça en
démonstration c'est vrai que là ça
chauffe un petit peu donc forcément
c'est pas évident du tout pendant que je
vous tiens même temps que vous
travaillez on en voit partout des
paniers sur nos marchés je pense
notamment marchés provençaux à des prix
défiant toute concurrence ne sont pas
délivrées par millions doses inédite moi
à quoi on reconnaît le vrai du faux
déjà souvent les vanneries qui ne sont
pas de chez nous et son vernis alors que
moi je prône vraiment le naturel le
local c'est très important des dents on
est dans une société donc je remplace
montbrun la cage et ouais si jacques à
ses employés très bien ok on on y sur
quel tarif a pas prête pour un panier en
osier fabriqué par un artisan comme roux
et ben la panique je vous ai ramené donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle une charlotte
doit elle typique de haute saône à
fougerolles c'était vraiment c'est des
cerises sommes donc là on est sur un
panier au moyenne à 65 euros
on vous cultivez vous transformez vous
travailler l'osier
j'insiste ans devra suivre tout de a à z
je cultive je transforme et je vais
pareillement un petit peu toutes ses
décorations qu'on a là en même temps que
vous travaillez dont alors qu' il faut
savoir que la vannerie c'est rentrer
dans les métiers d'art c'est uniquement
faire des paniers avant tout le monde
un peu tout le monde faisait des paniers
arrivée l'hiver en fonction des besoins
des récoltes le jardin tout ça est
maintenant sa rentrée dans les métiers
d'art donc du coup on a tendance à
l'éclosion on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut
parce que vous créez des pagny donc
voila sinon joueurs c'est quoi si pour
les fèves ou de décoration voilà on a
des mangeoires familiale
ouais on en a d'autres la bac celle-ci
là on peut faire toutes les formes
possibles avec toutes les couleurs
possibles quand donc les différences de
couleurs ses différentes variétés de
l'osier en fait donc
par exemple celui que je cultive sa
celui qui pousse le mieux chez nous et
qui est de bonne qualité manière sas
avait dû rouge belge par exemple on a un
deuxième essai qui fait un peu bleu et
du coup en haute marne on l'appelle
justement la bleue dites-moi l'osier
vivant
la preuve vous me disiez l'instant ça
vient de casser parce que vous n'avez
pas suffisamment arrosé
est-ce que moi si demain j'achète un
nouveau panier une de vos réalisations
avec encore une fois du vrai osier de
chez nous il va falloir que j'entretiens
non alors il n'ya pas d'entretien
spécifique après quand on n'a pas nié
admettons qu'on a un peu sali on peut le
passer un petit coup à l'eau tout
simplement et bien le faire sécher
derrière ça lui fera du bien ça leur
nourrira un petit peu vous faites des
ateliers pour les enfants
alors j'imagine que à l'image de votre
garçon marcel qui peut-être en régie
qu'une en garde qui a deux ans et que je
salue
voilà parce qu'il peut ne pas être avec
ne sont pas de l'oci faisait un petit
peu de bruit qu'est-ce qui vous
demandent le plus les enfants
qu'est-ce qui nous demandent le plus
avec les enfants souvent travaillé sur
un petit fou en contreplaqué comme ça
parce qu'on voit là non tout de suite on
a été obligé de faire un front qui est
quand même tout de suite plus technique
donc sur un petit four en contreplaqué
on va mettre des brins qu'on appelle les
montants et ils ont tissé autour donc là
j'étais en forme un peu des tipis
souvent leur fait faire des petits pots
à crayons ou alors des petits supports
pour y mettre une plante de damparis et
ce garçon s'appelle merrill un blu voilà